last night we were the first to bring
you this disturbing video that sent
shockwaves through the American law
enforcement community and beyond
disgusting and depressing but this is
not an isolated incident this is what
everyone has to understand this is just
the latest in a long line of examples
that demonstrate a growing disrespect
for the people and principles that most
Americans still hold dear since we
showed you that awful video last night
another shocking incident surface from
Harlem as officers there attempted to
make an arrest now the reaction to these
kinds of attacks was fierce as you heard
right here on the Ingraham angle it
makes me sick to our friends in New York
if you don't take care of your cops
shame on you
it wouldn't happen if we didn't have a
progressive retro aggressive completely
lazy mayor in New York City who is
absolutely destroying the quality of
life in this city he's a disgrace though
some in the community were still willing
to downplay it it seemed like the
officers were okay with a little water a
little street fun because people have
been throwing water balloons and dousing
each other so that's not uncommon
unbelievable just like there were some
folks who didn't bat an eye hearing
things like this
[Music]
remember that was during the Obama years
the disrespect of the police has been
building since the height of the
anti-vietnam war movement now it was
during the chaos outside the 1968
Democratic convention in Chicago when
protesters began using the term Pig to
describe police officers the youth
international party hippies they call
themselves converged on Chicago
they said they were there to protest the
war poverty racism and other social ills
some of them were also determined to
provoke a confrontation well of course
the disrespect of our military vets
followed when they returned from
overseas we did what we was asked to do
okay a lot of people didn't like it
there was a lot of flak about it when we
came back we were spit on we called
baby-killer so forth and so on but we
did what we felt we needed to do for our
country god bless him and then President
Reagan remember brought us morning in
America and he helped inspire a new
generation of young patriots who were
eager to turn the page on that
unfortunate chapter of course that
didn't stop the left which had already
burrowed into our colleges and into our
universities spreading their view that
Reagan was just a war monger and America
was an evil imperialist force and all
the while the entertainment industry was
doing its part
slowly but surely ridiculing and
demonizing and disrespecting Republican
presidents and the office of the
presidency the disrespect reached every
aspect of popular culture as filmmakers
and producers pretty much ridiculed
everything about traditional American
values and replace them with something
more progressive or too many of us
regressive public and private schools
began to disrespect America's Founding
by teaching a watered down version of
history approved by the politically
correct censors the study of great books
by old white racist men well that was
out and Howard Zinn's radical a people's
history of the United States was in so
after all these years later should it
really come
a surprise when four freshman
Congresswoman equate the crisis at our
border to one of history's greatest
atrocities United States is running
concentration camps on our southern
border Alexandria Ocasio Cortez your
colleague who was at the border with you
compared the facilities to a
concentration camp do you agree with
that comparison absolutely I mean there
are camps and people are being
concentrated this is very simple but
this just isn't I got garden-variety
case of historical illiteracy no no no
no we've also seen a disrespect of art
history itself - in its full sweep as
statues and markers that people had
walked by and driven by for decades
being ripped down because someone
somewhere called them offensive even the
American flag is disrespected or
reprieves from the 1960s and the
national anthem which we all once stood
for is now a point itself of controversy
sit it out and you're a hero question
the kneelers and you're a villain if we
don't respect ourselves our traditions
and our turns of our history we can't
expect our young people or frankly
visitors to our country to respect them
either you know this is a memorial for
the soldiers right
memorial for the soldiers it's not it's
not for swimming that was actually at
the World War Two memorial here in
Washington DC a year or so ago people
swimming not knowing what it really is
just treating it like a day at the beach
commemorating of course all those who
sacrificed for our Liberty in World War
two unbelievable also let's face it many
don't even respect the need to protect
innocent life unborn or even after
they're born the bill is passed and we
don't respect each other even in front
of children
and onlookers too many don't respect the
men and women of ice or the Border
Patrol many of whom were Hispanic by the
way and also in uniform 99.5% of them
doing their best under extremely
difficult circumstances I think we need
to abolish ice abolishing ice protects
my families from the militarization that
is happening in our neighborhoods listen
to the words of disrespect this isn't
minor criticism of the government or
even vigorous criticism of the
government this is a wholesale effort to
burn it down and Lord knows that on
social media we don't respect each other
at all Democrats and we Republicans can
all do better but back to how we started
how we treat the men and women in
uniform many black Americans believe
that they are unfairly targeted by
police and many police officers believe
they're unfairly targeted to well
they're just trying to do their jobs and
this is how things end up
young men sitting in a car laughing and
what they think is the humiliation of
police officers who are doing everything
they could their jobs knowing they'll
post the video you bet which will get
them a lot of likes and maybe some more
yucks
no wonder so many cities are having
trouble recruiting police today would
you subject yourself to this abuse day
in and day out perhaps it was Mike
Huckabee last night who said it best
when there's a crime in the neighborhood
call on somebody with a water hose see
how that works out for you respect and
the lack of it that's the angle